you don't want to be secure you want to
be strong and you get strong by taking
on optimal challenges how do you wake up
every day and make sure you're doing
something to push yourself forward you
have to remind yourself that it's okay
to feel the way you feel when you're
going through a difficult time rise and
shine it's an espresso time what's up
believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message take on challenges over to you
Jordan B Peterson if you want to know
what Jordan Peterson and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
if you're gonna speak effectively you
have to know way more than you're
talking about
[Music]
we're built for struggle as human beings
you not after the bubbles of bliss that
Dostoyevsky described in in notes from
underground
we're built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want a challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because the
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and fortune might do
you in but it's your best bet and you
know people have also people that have
extracted unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures and so and I'm not
saying that in a naive way I know
perfectly well what happens to people
you know you're doing fine in life and
then you get cancer and then six months
later you're dead and all the heroism in
the world isn't going to save you at
that point but that's not the point
that's not the point life is bounded by
mortality but that doesn't mean that you
don't get out there and contend and
develop by contending and you minimize
the net amount of suffering in the world
and that's something man that's
something to do winning without struggle
does not feel like a win it doesn't feel
like you're winning that's why the
context becomes so important if you were
to run a race against three-year-olds
you would win but you wouldn't feel
great about yourself because there was
no struggle involved the greater the
struggle and you come out on the other
side the more you feel like you have a
big win so as an example every morning I
get out of bed and I go with my wife to
the local coffee shop and then I come
home and I start my work that's not a
big win that's easy for me to do but for
some people just getting out of bed is a
big win for some people just moving
their right arm up is a big win and so
that's why the context becomes so so so
important my current struggle right now
is making these ain't stressful videos
better I put a lot of pressure on myself
to make these and spresso videos better
and because I struggle so much with them
as I get better at them it actually
feels like a solid win and so I'm
working with my agent to review my
videos to go over them dissect them look
at ways to make them better I spend way
more time on these videos in the span of
making five videos now is what I used to
spend making all 22 of my inst restive
videos so there's way more effort being
put into each one and because the
struggle is so real to try to improve
them then every time that we get a win
that we get better results and it
actually feels like a solid win because
there's so much struggle behind it ok so
how do you do it
how do you take on challenges how do you
wake up every day and make sure you're
doing something to push yourself forward
and set up Costain everyday I'm gonna
give you three tips that can help you
number one is match your actions to your
ambitions match your actions to your
ambitions for a lot of us a lot of
entrepreneur you have great ambitions
you talk a great game you can dream and
imagine a great world ahead of you but
are you actually doing the work it's
great to go to a motivational seminar or
even just watch one of these videos and
get all pumped up but are you doing the
work what you should do every time you
feel bold courageous motivated is
immediately go to your calendar go to
your schedule make sure that what you
are doing on a weekly basis map to you
actually accomplishing your goals look
at your calendar look at what's in front
of you and goals not just for
your business goals all your goals your
personal goals your financial goals your
relationship goals all your goals look
at what your goals are and then look at
what you are going to be doing as tasks
for the next week
and is what's in your calendar if you
did those things if you sat down you did
the work everything that's in your
calendar would you move closer to
accomplishing your goals or not and for
too many of you it's not for too many of
you you have big dreams big ambitions
but your actions don't map up you're not
doing the work that will get you closer
to accomplishing your goals so make sure
the next time if you're motivated do it
right now after this video look at your
schedule and make sure that the actions
that are in your calendar are mapping
towards you accomplishing your ambitions
number two is tie your worth to effort
not the result this is such a huge one
tie your worth tie yourself respect
yourself esteem to the effort that you
are putting in on a regular basis not
just the results this is where people
make a huge mistake because you try
something you try it once you don't get
results you try to make youtube video
you don't get results I try to make my
own special videos better I don't get
results right you try you try you try
try a couple times you don't get results
and then you feel like a failure because
you didn't get the results
flip it don't care about the results the
results will happen if you continue to
put in the effort these in special
videos will get better if I continue to
put in the effort whatever your goal
your ambition is if you keep putting in
the work you will eventually accomplish
your goal but if you keep tying your
self-respect your self-esteem to the
results that you're getting you won't
put in enough effort so I want you to
take massive action I want you to take
massive daily action I want you to be
able to hit your pillow tonight when
you're going to sleep and be proud not
of the results that you got don't worry
about that it will come be proud of the
effort that you put in can you go to
sleep tonight put your head on the
pillow and be proud and say I am so
insanely proud of the effort that I
poured in to getting closer to my goal
today because if you did that if you
felt that way every single day being
insanely proud of the effort that you're
put in and I promise you I promise you
the results will come
and your life will look unrecognizable
one year from today if you took that
approach to life every single day
compared to where you are right now tie
your worth to the effort not the results
and number three is flex TX one of my
favorite things to do is flex the X and
what that means is and take a calendar
of the year
take a calendar and you set your goals
the main habits that you need to do like
this habits if you follow through on
these habits then you would get closer
to accomplishing your goals right these
are the habits and every day that you do
the habit you put the X you put the X
you put the X you put the X you're
flexing the X momentum is one of the
biggest thing that is missing for so
many entrepreneurs because you might
take on a big challenge one day and you
feel great and courageous and bold and
unstoppable and then super proud of your
effort and then what happens the next
day it's gone poof what happened and
this is the challenge for entrepreneurs
is that you're not consistently taking
action is that it's not that you don't
take action is that you're not
consistent in the habits that you set
for yourself and so flex the X print off
a yearly calendar figure out the one or
two habits that you want to make sure
that you are doing every single day and
then when you do it put an X on that box
feel the momentum you don't want to
break the chain you want to make sure
that it's going every single day and if
you keep that up if you had matched your
actions to your ambitions if you're
tying your self-worth your self-respect
to the effort that you're putting in and
you were taking the daily actions and
flexing the X you will accomplish your
ambitions I think humans love challenges
I think entrepreneurs love challenges I
think it feels like an amazing win when
you go through something difficult and
you end up on the other side the answer
when you're faced with the challenge
isn't a play small isn't the stay where
you are
isn't the find excuses and reasons why
you can't do it that's negative
self-talk that that is deprecating to
your self-respect
the answer is to dive into that
challenge and find a way to overcome it
and hopefully those three tips helped
you now I've got a really special bonus
clip that I think you're going to enjoy
but before that question of the day I
want to know what is the big challenge
that you want to take on right now let
me know put it down in the comments
below
you have to remind yourself that it's
okay to feel the way you feel when
you're going for a difficult time it's
okay to feel weak it's okay to want to
cry it's okay to feel overwhelmed just
reminding yourself that it's okay this
is my number one way of how to find
strength in difficult times
is reminding yourself that the way you
feel is okay to honor that feeling to
accept that feeling to actually be okay
with that what we see or what we
perceive to be a weakness or what we
perceive to let us down or what we
perceive is a sign of you know
instability or insecurity we've got to
remind ourselves that when things are
tough it's okay to feel that way there's
nothing wrong with that any difficulty I
go to I look to moments in history where
people have endured the same pain if not
more extreme and analyze absorb and
connect with how they got through it I
like to see what they were thinking I
like to see what they did I like to see
how they structured themselves I like to
look at how they organized I looked like
to look at who they were speaking to I
like to look at what was going through
their mind at that time because you've
got to remember that any challenge we're
facing today we've faced it before as a
as humanity right beyond ethnicities
beyond color race creed beyond
backgrounds beyond all walks of life as
human beings we've been through
challenges before and we've got through
them and therefore reconnecting with how
that's been done before is a beautiful
way of learning how to overcome current
challenges so you can either look at
your past but real wisdom lies in
looking at the past of people who made a
difference you look at people like
Martin Luther King you look at people
like Gandhi you look at people who made
world-changing differences not
single-handedly but influenced from a
single perspective from a single point
of view and really connecting with the
powerful moments in history I've said
this quote many times I've read it many
times and this quote actually is is
unbelievable and the quote says that
they fought they buried us they didn't
know we were see
right it's a Mexican Bravo they thought
they borrowed us they didn't know we
were seeds and I was thinking these when
you tell yourself that story
you start thinking much more differently
right a seed is buried - it's incredible
that the seed goes through the same
process as anything else it's put deep
underground right all of this mud is put
on top of it it gets rained on it gets
snowed on all these kind of things but
it knows that it's a seed so it knows
that it can grow so there anything's
possible and it grows through and you
see even plants going to concrete
sometimes right it's unbelievable how
much power a seed has so changing the
stories we tell ourselves we can either
look at challenging situations as
opportunities for growth as an
opportunity to learn as an opportunity
to change be the change we can look at
them and and really fool down now that
that second part is okay we can even
feel like that right but we have to
recognize it's not permanent
we've gotta accept that none of our
feelings are permanent they don't need
to be permanent it's a choice so if you
need to vent vent I was saying to
someone yesterday if you need a vent
vent if you need to run run if you need
to complain complain if you need to
share if you do that but recognize that
those feelings are not permanent and
it'll be amazing when we've realized we
are seeds right that is the most
powerful way of finding strength what do
you think is the biggest risk you've
ever taken either as an actor producer
or both I I mean I think just the the
biggest risk was convincing myself that
I was going to try to earn a living as a
comedy person yeah that was probably the
biggest flying leap and I you know I did
all the typical things of maxing out all
my credit cards and living pretty much
hand to mouth and trying to explain to
my parents why it was a good idea and
that was definitely the yeah the biggest
other I mean and the beta's biggest
creative challenge I ever did was
filming Casa de mi padre which is a
movie
entirely in Spanish I did that yeah I'm
always kind of looking for ways to
challenge myself raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people with passion and
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's something serene if you liked
this video and want more Jordan Peterson
check out the twelve rules for life
video that I made on him the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
you don't know enough and the Riu can
tell you don't know enough because your
life is not what it could be and neither
is the life of the people around you